nick is with us in Kansas hi Nick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi David thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so I'm having a little bit of
trouble dealing with my money with my
parents and I want to be one more
gizelle intent about standing up for my
emergency fund is baby step 3 um so
currently I live with them I'm only 23
years old so I mean you know work in
trying to save up money but I feel like
it's fair for me to help them out but
you know it's like I feel like the
spending I've got a little a little more
over the top in the past couple months
and kind of like I I've talked to them a
couple times and we don't really get
anywhere if we do we don't really follow
through you know mm-hmm um so beyond me
so what is your in what is your income
I make seventy nine thousand why do you
still live at home well because my
parents aren't really making that much
in the first place the support them and
my little sibling mm-hmm okay well I
think the first thing needs to happen is
you need to move out that's the first
thing it's very difficult to set
boundaries or someone who's providing
your housing I'd say it's a parent-child
thing is now confused you're 23 year old
young man and they still view you as a
16 year old with a really cool lawn
cutting job mm-hmm okay is that is that
possible I'm what you think I might be
right
I mean I'm not disregarding that the way
it's like I don't know they it's I mean
they're in their early sixties and
they're struggling to make ends meet on
by themselves why why well my dad he ran
how's his emergency son recently after
losing his job and how did he lose his
job I'm sorry say again why did he lose
his job things weren't going well his
boss
mm-hmm and this has been a pattern in
his life maybe not not particularly
okay so what did he used to make um I
personally don't know that mm-hmm
okay does your mom work she does
part-time okay all right so you make
$80,000 a year almost you're 23 years
old what you do for a living I'm a
topper engineer
okay I do not think you're going to be
able to fix your parents ID Hey
I think you can love your parents well
and probably the best way to love them
and even help them some financially
would be from a little bit more of a
distance I think this has become toxic
you living there because it's so
confusing to them and you if you don't
watch you're gonna be 33 and they're
going to be in their 70s and still
unemployed now you're supporting the
whole kit and caboodle mm-hmm which
makes you what's known as an ineligible
bachelor at that point no no girl wants
to marry that guy true okay all right
well I mean that's where this is heading
it sounds like because it sounds like
this is a lifelong pattern for mom and
dad and you can love them and you can
even give them some money but I would do
it from a distance I think you're going
to struggle to set healthy boundaries
and have a quality adult to adult
relationship with them until you move
out and you certainly can afford to move
out and so I you make 79,000 you can
just move out tomorrow and then if you
want to support them for a little while
and give them 500 bucks a month or
something or $1,000 a month or whatever
you want to do until they get back to
work and you set some boundaries on that
said this is only gonna be for four
months ad you got to get back to work
and you can do that kind of aim it's a
little difficult to do that when you
live under his roof it just confuses
things
[Music]